Veteran English actor Oliver Reed died before
finishing all of his scenes for Ridley Scott's
2000 epic Gladiator.
This forced Scott to engage in some digital
trickery with outtakes to depict the death
of Reed's character, gladiator handler Proximo.
But the circumstances surrounding Reed's death
serve to illustrate two things about the man:
he was every bit as tough as his onscreen
persona suggested, and he was a bit too fond
of liquor for his own good.
The film was shot on location in Malta, and
on the night before he was to shoot his final
scenes, Reed celebrated by dropping in on
a local pub.
He put down eight pints of lager before moving
on to a dozen double shots of rum and half
a bottle of whiskey.
Then he proceeded to take on a crew of British
Navy sailors in an arm-wrestling contest,
defeating them all before finally preparing
to retire for the night.
But after decades of such behavior, Reed's
body had finally had enough.
He suffered a massive heart attack, and dropped
dead on the spot.
The pub where he died has come to be known
as "Ollie's Last Pub."
Fans the world over come through to browse
its collection of memorabilia, have a pint
or three, and pay tribute to one of the most
legendary tough guys in film history.
But his complete list of credits is longer
than your arm.
Among them were the 1973 version of The Three
Musketeers and its 1989 sequel, The Return
of the Musketeers, both directed by Kinnear's
frequent collaborator Richard Lester.
Alas, the latter ending up being his final
role.
Kinnear was injured in a fall from a horse
during the shoot in Spain, and he was subsequently
admitted to a hospital in Madrid.
His injuries weren't considered life-threatening,
but they were apparently too much for his
body.
He suffered a heart attack the next day while
still in the hospital, and doctors weren't
able to save him.
Kinnear's untimely death had a profound effect
on the film's cast and crew, but none were
so affected as Lester, who had lost a dear
friend.
1987's Million Dollar Mystery was as much
a gimmick as it was a film.
Its cast of zany characters spent the entire
runtime hunting down a series of three cash
stashes of one million dollars hidden somewhere
in the United States.
The ending revealed that the third stash of
hidden loot was totally real, as it challenged
audiences to use clues from the film to determine
its location.
The movie was widely ignored when it wasn't
being roundly panned, but its most unfortunate
legacy lies in the accident that took the
life of stuntman Dar Robinson.
Widely considered by his peers to be one of
the gutsiest stunt workers alive, Robinson
held a number of insane records, including
the highest fall ever put on film.
He had somehow never suffered an on-set injury
in his career, but that changed in the most
tragic fashion possible during the shooting
of a routine motorcycle chase sequence.
Robinson went into a curve at a high speed
on his Honda 600 dirt bike, losing control
and skidding off the road.
He was separated from the bike, thrown down
an embankment and impaled by a sagebrush branch.
He was airlifted to a hospital, but his injuries
ended up killing him.
John Jordan was among the most fearless camera
operators who ever lived, having developed
his own perilous technique of getting the
kind of aerial shots that simply shouldn't
have been possible.
Secured only by a harness, with his feet resting
on the skid of a helicopter, he would lean
out into the blue to secure his amazing shots.
It was during the filming of one such aerial
sequence for the James Bond film You Only
Live Twice that he came a little too close
to one of his subjects, a Bell 47 helicopter.
One of its blades struck and almost removed
his foot, which eventually had to be amputated.
But Jordan was undeterred, and he went right
back to work doing what he did best.
This gung-ho attitude finally caught up with
him in 1969 while shooting Catch-22.
Jordan was acting as second-unit director,
shooting from the open door of a B25 bomber.
Once again, a passing aircraft got a little
bit too close, but rather than making contact,
it created a freak gust of wind that threw
the B25 off to one side.
Jordan lost his balance, got too close to
the door, and was promptly sucked out.
He plummeted to his death 4,000 feet into
the ocean.
While not a household name, director, actor,
and stunt driver Toby Halicki won himself
a cult following in the 1970s by virtue of
being preternaturally gifted at the art of
filming car chases and crashes.
His sophomore effort, 1974's Gone in 60 Seconds,
is a prime example of this gift.
But during the filming of its 1989 sequel,
Halicki met his end in a bizarre accident
that strangely had nothing to do with his
insanely dangerous stunt work.
While filming in Tonawanda, New York, the
crew was setting up to shoot the collapse
of a water tower for a scene that Tonawanda
officials had tried mightily to prevent.
Halicki had been forced to take out an $8
million insurance policy in order to get them
to relent, and he had announced his plans
to sue the city upon the film's completion.
But as it turned out, he probably should've
paid more attention to their concerns.
The tower collapsed prematurely, causing an
attached steel cable to snap.
The cable then knocked over a nearby telephone
pole, which fell directly on top of Halicki.
He was treated by EMTs at the scene to no
avail, and he was pronounced dead on arrival
at the local hospital.
Halicki's widow Denice served as an executive
producer on the 2000 remake of Gone in 60
Seconds as a means of preserving her husband's
legacy.
2008's The Dark Knight featured some incredible
stunt work in conjunction with spectacular,
and sometimes dangerous, practical effects.
Among the stunt performers working on the
film was Conway Wickliffe, a 41-year-old veteran
of the industry.
While shooting a portion of the Tumbler/Batcycle
chase sequence, Wickliffe was in the process
of capturing a fairly standard shot when tragedy
struck.
He was filming a stunt car while hanging out
the window of an SUV.
His vehicle's driver inexplicably veered off
course, failing to follow his prescribed route
and instead plowing through a grassy area,
a detour that ended with a crash into a tree.
Despite the fact that the SUV was only going
about 20 miles per hour, Wickliffe sustained
injuries serious enough that he was pronounced
dead at the scene.
His untimely demise was, unfortunately, a
harbinger of things to come, as star Heath
Ledger died of an accidental drug overdose
shortly before the film's release.
The shocking deaths of both men were memorialized
in The Dark Knight's closing credits.
In 1978, residents of Lexington, Kentucky
were thrilled to have a real Hollywood production
in town.
It was Steel, starring and produced by Lexington
native Lee Majors.
The film's climax called for its villain to
plummet from a skyscraper to his death, and
the city's Kincaid Towers, which were nearing
completion, were just the ticket.
The fall was performed by 27-year old A.J.
Bakunas, who at one time held the record for
the highest fall, and the scene had been completed
with Bakunas jumping from the ninth story
into an airbag.
But then Bakunas got word that Dar Robinson
had recently broken his record, causing him
to insist on shooting the scene again, making
the jump from the top of the 323-foot tower
this time.
The on-set physician tried desperately to
halt the attempt.
But Bakunas, intent on regaining his record,
wouldn't change his mind.
He performed the fall, and struck the airbag
squarely in the prescribed area, only to have
it rupture.
Amazingly, despite having just fallen hundreds
of feet essentially onto concrete, Bakunas
initially clung to life.
But although his head and internal organs
had escaped serious injury, his lungs had
taken too much damage.
He died the next day.
In February 2014, a 20-person film crew showed
up for work on the biopic Midnight Rider,
the life story of rocker Gregg Allman.
Director Randall Miller had them shoot scenes
on an active train track, assuring them that
it was in use only by two trains, both of
which had already gone by.
In the unlikely event that another train appeared,
they were told they'd have only sixty seconds
to clear the track.
That ended up being not nearly enough time,
as a third train made an unexpected appearance
in the middle of the shoot.
The locomotive was traveling at a speed close
to 60 miles per hour.
It struck a bed which had been affixed to
the tracks, sending debris flying.
27-year old camera operator Sarah Jones was
somehow pushed into the path of the train,
which struck and killed her instantly.
Miller subsequently became the first filmmaker
to be convicted on a criminal charge related
to events on a film set.
He pled guilty to involuntary manslaughter
and was sentenced to two years in prison,
with eight years of probation to follow, while
Midnight Rider was canceled.